he's the Commissioner of the SEC Greg
sank he's back with us commissioner
thanks for joining us
how would you recap the weekend in the
SEC well try not to add to your
frustration on a Monday morning how
about if I start there really but he
issues of the day you go back to
statement I made Thursday night about as
being past time for change to the state
flag in Mississippi um you saw just to
cover all the bases reports about
quarantine II around Cove at 19 on some
of our campuses not necessarily all
positive tests I think we have to be
intentional about how we can UK Saturday
in fact it wasn't until Sunday I saw a
group of football players from Ole Miss
post a video take a stand and we for
change on a monument that appears in the
square at Oxford so I think that's real
life in 20 point isn't it that's exactly
the type of issues for dealing with its
unprecedent in some ways but a reality
to change is a constant in our life
whether we want to acknowledge that
change or not can Ole Miss continue to
be Ole Miss I'm sure I think that's
that's up to them there's a lot going
going on right now in those
conversations I think I look at it my
responsibility is as a conference
commissioner because we have so much
they can go on we have Championships
we'll go out to bid you know and we have
others that rotate that I needed to take
that stand and I know that their
Chancellor and their campus leadership
has worked hard up issues when you have
things in place for years sometimes it
takes time to work through everything go
back to you know the banning of sticks
is a way to deal with the flag issue
back in the 90s and that was the
leadership needed then we've got a
different type of leadership expectation
now the number of positive tests over
the weekend i I don't can you explain
the process do coaches have to tell you
what has happened on their campus with
their football teams no we don't rely on
our coaches for that information we have
a weekly call with a medical advisory
committee group we've been working with
several months now and those are medical
leaders tied either to their athletics
program in the university so we'll
receive updates there and and again I
think that's where it's important to
understand their testing outcomes and
then there is essentially tracing
outcomes where because of potential
contacts quarantine takes place even
though someone may not have tested
positive for Kovac 19 what kind of
options are you looking at for the
season yeah I describe this as a
marathon and really I caught the end of
your previous segment on the returned
activities that may or may not happen at
major league baseball and other sports I
know they're all preparing for that
we're living that reality we're dealing
literally with voluntary athletic
related activities and we know that
within our facilities we can provide the
kind of care and oversight that guides
people in the right way keeps them
healthy we're also learning that 19 and
20 year olds will do what 19 and 20 year
olds do and that is maybe not listen to
all the advice that exists I think their
immunity level or their their strength
and conditioning can prevent them from
being having a positive test or
contracting a virus and I think that's a
lesson that everyone still has to learn
that the discussions about masks and how
we maintain our health these are real
issues that help us move forward or
we're still months away from what could
be the potential kickoff that's our
focus but as I've said repeatedly we
have to prepare to adjust to the
circumstances just like we're adjusting
right now after the last four or five
days what will those adjustment wait
what are the possible and maybe you
don't want to get into hypotheticals to
be fair to you but I everybody's
optimistic about this Commissioner but
man I I just I don't know I have serious
doubts about how we're gonna pull all
any of this off I really am
nobody like nobody on my side of the
microphone when you're asked questions
has been overly optimistic and I'm
certainly realistic it is it is a
marathon and I don't know where the
finish line is and in my life I finished
41 marathons and at least I knew with
the exception of one where they
measured that the finish line was 26.2
miles you can imagine my frustration out
I knew it felt longer that was and here
we know there's a finish line but where
is it and so then I have to look at this
as each step and a couple of weeks ago
we opened up our athletic facilities
again voluntary activities what you're
seeing now in the news is a reaction to
the plans that were put in place today
is another milestone the NCAA made a
decision to allow an elevated level of
practice I'll call it come July 3rd I
think that's the next stage and right
around that time we'll have to come to
some conclusions on whether we can move
forward as planned or not was this
planned or this was expected that you
would have these kids test positive well
it was prepared for the goal was never
to expect 0 that's just not reality
around us it is the Binet the plan was
test when they arrived we had positive
Testament people came back and we have
embedded medical professionals in our
athletics program that's part of what I
think gets missed is the level of care
provided for young people on our
campuses on a daily basis and then there
was preparation for the what ifs and so
those hypotheticals that I have avoided
answering are very much a part of
planning what do we do if bunch of
people go to a party where someone tests
positive you're going to be in
quarantine what do we do if there's a
positive test what do we do and they
come back how many people can be allowed
in a facility what is the spacing what
is the expectation when you walk in and
leave what is the continuing
reinforcement about the education
provided that well you made it through
one week doesn't make you make doesn't
mean you'll make it through two unless
you take care of yourselves and there
are no guarantee if you can go back to
March where we all thought we were
playing basketball tournaments at March
Madness what happened we made
assumptions and we have fewer
assumptions made and that's why we have
to prepare for a whole set of
contingencies we talked about it last
time and like if you can give me an
update with the SCC maybe just have
conference games like the is the game
plan to have just
Conference games or is it a full slate
we've we've gone through I think we're
just short of twenty scenarios the the
plan the focus is to prepare the play as
scheduled and then to pivot off of that
and there are any number of options that
could allow an entire schedule to be
played both conference non conference
but everybody in this country has to be
a part of that at the collegiate level
that's just a little bit more complex
than say the NFL putting its schedule
out there delaying because all of those
things are controlled by a central
entity so I think we'll keep that focus
but we'll plan for contingencies that
could be you know probably anything you
read about from a speculative standpoint
maybe just Alabama and LSU play 12 times
you know I can take one of those a year
I imagine the stress level in my life
bearings right now it's not summer
commissioner thank you we appreciate
your time and good luck well I
appreciate the continued conversation
thank you it's a Greg Sankey the
Commissioner of the SEC